let's look at modern remote debugging
with Chrome I'm gonna take the euro this
demo and open it up in chrome on Android
now
remote debugging page we see it's GPU
layers more on that later what I really
want to show you is this screen casting
you're looking at the live view of
chrome on Android on your machine it
shows exactly what's happening on the
device all the time but better than that
you can actually interact with it so
typing here with my fingers is slow
let's switch to the keyboard yeah
so all keystrokes are sent down to the
device and clicks and drags are sent
down as touches too you can scroll with
your mouse wheel and or trackpad and see
your device scroll with you and probably
my favorite is yep inspect element it
works the way you'd want it to selecting
the elements in the devices browser and
manipulating them directly now back to
those GPU layers here's a complex a 3d
CSS transform scene and dev tools gives
us insight on the live layer tree
composition similarly screen casted
remote debugging works great with the
WebGL profiler
please try all this out today for how to
scuba for remote debugging thanks